Chuy cho sống sống tình kì hi bị vui lấp chính này, sẽ buồn đơn, sống sư báo dạy.
Cơ chuyện về gí được sống của Chuy cho tên Micky ở Inbai,
đang được lãnh toả như một câu chuyện về đẹp tiên và phép mỏ cho cuộc sống.
Được biến, Micky bị vui lấp trong canya sau chả sạch lỡ đất kinh hoàn sâu egg gửp của bảo sua.
Cả tớ thể hoại chưu chức đau của Micky bị chân dưới lức mồn đặc sêb.
Không thích ăn nước uống, lui, chân và mỗi bắt của em, không đá bị tơ, nhưng em vẫn kiến cửa trên đấu.
Sống chỉ nghề em được phát hiện và được mọi người đưa ra khỏi vui nhà đồn át,
năm trước bệnh viện thu y 2 tần em đã hệ mật chờ lại và tiếp tục sự hiệp trong nhà.
Với chúng ta cũng vậy, dù hồn trong hành cạnh khô khăn nào,
hãy luôn dưới vấn nhiệm tiên vào cuộc sống, chắc chẳng nghề mai tây sáng vẫn đang đợi chúng ta.
Thầm mới Micky, bởi em là điều tốt đẹp nhất còn lại cho sự hóa tàn.